you know you can't change the world you
have to start with yourself I was going
down a one-way street going backwards
and I left the house I had my gun on my
hip I kept a blunt halfway lift
had my tennis shoes tied tight these
guys I had to jump out the chyron I
didn't trust nobody
for all I knew one of my homeboys were
shooting in the back of my head I was
always a soldier all the soldier in
their own army how did I let my life get
this far down the road you know how did
I forget what my roots was growing up I
didn't have a father we didn't have much
money but my mom always told us you know
God is going to provide God is going to
provide my life was pretty stable but at
the same time I was having to deal with
my mom mental illness is my mom he
caught her Dexter doctors laboratory
she looked like a nerd with all the
glasses all she had I smell the
Gunpowder some totally your mommy just
committed suicide
it hurt him so bad mom why would you
leaving why would you leave after my mom
passed my sisters and my brother dating
really see eye to eye and my stepdad he
ran off the house eventually was just
empty lights was off and it was just me
and I was 16 I will wake up in the
morning I will go to the living room
where we all used to eat breakfast that
I waited I thought my brothers and
sisters were gonna come back home lights
was gonna be back home one day and it
was gonna be just like the day before
mama passed
[Music]
it never happened it never happened in
the city of Flint Michigan all is
excitement the older boys and girls are
let out of school all this is a day the
whole town's a fossil yes siree
there's going to be a parade too growing
up you hear how Flint was a thriving
city
Flint was the American dream
you
[Music]
flat Mishka
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
michiel ed when I say he's my youngest
baby she's three he had to say yourself
it's not right we didn't ask for the
lifestyle that we grew up in GM build
the neighborhood and they left it kind
of left my generation from like we were
cheated because it was gang infested the
whole crack epidemic popped off and then
our houses was condemned or either just
non livable the city just destroy
yourself this view of achieve much
England's by our recognition our Father
which are in heaven hallowed be thy name
I came to come thy will be done
I tried raising myself for a while that
didn't work a lot of my friend she's
come around we still didn't sell drugs
or anything like that but we stole
anything and get our hands on to survive
scheming this got me turned into a bad
police record and amusing the streets my
kid had to step over a k47 to get to the
breakfast table unless God did something
things he did to break the yoke on my
life I definitely was headed toward
destruction
I was getting shot up early going in my
house and hitting the couch I looked at
the bullet aside I'm over there the
streets is not a joke if somebody comes
shoot at you you better retaliate or
either the next guy's going to do it and
that guy's going to do it so I went to
go retaliate and I got one bullet off
and my gun and jam I took that as a sign
God is protecting me for a reason to
help community
this bar so we ask that you make a
testimony out of everybody or don't ever
lie to my
[Music]
I've never killed anyone but I felt
guilty for a lot of things and I feel
like it was blood on my hands my pastor
called me into his office water playing
old Flint water he washed my hands
physically washed my hands took some I
like pastor and seen my soul I seen what
I really could become it's time to wake
up it's time to grow up it's time to
take our city back there's a program
that my church has provided it's the
real brass roof perspective for changing
flint black metal image in Flint is put
up to be dug his roof but at the same
time I'm guarantee every night wonderful
run just tell you what just was personal
happiness it didn't have the right
guidance give away water fruit lad test
it's a way to help the community I'm the
supervisor to lawn care service we're
cutting most of the lots that were
previously vacant homes that were tore
down
but it does has changed the whole view
of the neighborhood just the elder lady
come outside in her hat just and she
just want to watch and watch her
neighborhood her neighborhood will come
back I love it
if there's one thing that people should
know about Flint is that we've been
survivor since day one the day my mom
put that revolver up to her head it made
me fight fight fight and fight but
everything I've been through my job is
to teach to break the cycle when you put
the man together the world comes
together
as to being a part of problem we're part
of solution a permanent part of solution
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]